the Senate Intelligence Committee
released commis Oatman statement
yesterday at his request it previews
what he will say in one of the most
highly anticipated congressional
hearings in hearings in years James
Comey says the president told him quote
I need loyalty I expect loyalty during a
White House jenner statement also
confirms reports that mr. Trump asked
Comey to let go of the investigation a
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn and James Comey revealed he told
the president three times that he was
not personally under investigation we
have a team of correspondents covering
this story from Washington to Moscow
Nancy Cordes is inside the hearing room
on Capitol Hill Nancy good morning good
morning and according to some newly
released excerpts the top Democrat on
this committee Virginia's Mark Warner
will describe those conversations today
between Comey and the president as
disturbing in his opening statement
Warner will say this is not how a
President of the United States behaves
now he's referring to commis written
testimony released yesterday that
describes a series of one-on-one
meetings that Comey himself says he
thought were very concerning
he described for instance a January
dinner at the White House where there
was an awkward silence after the
president told Comey point-blank I need
loyalty in subsequent conversations the
president asked Comey to help lift the
cloud of the Russia investigation the
director told him the FBI was
investigating the matter as quickly as
we could now senators are going to have
seven minutes each to question Comey
here today and there are 17 of them this
could go into a second round so he'll
definitely be here for a while guys all
right Nancy thank you so much